foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear we're talking about a classic today
so when you look back on it uh 1960 was
a hell of a year for horror uh three
movies in particular that were released
that year made a huge huge impact on the
genre going forward
um and I'd argue that their influence is
still felt in the genre nowadays so you
know this many years later two of these
were of course Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho
which is of course a seminal film and
the Lesser known but likewise like just
as important I think uh peeping Tom the
British film directed by Michael Powell
which we read a little while back but
the third movie in that Holy Trinity I
can at least in my opinion I think it
actually kind of went farther than
either of those at least in terms of
like Gore being gruesome or whatever and
was for my money also the most
disturbing of the three I think because
maybe because it has kind of list this
real like weird like Poetic Beauty to it
but then it's like kind of in Parts as
like really overtly grotesque and it
also has this really weird like clinical
like matter-of-fact kind of tone which
really like highlights the gruesome like
really effectively so the movie I'm
talking about obviously is George
franzu's Eyes Without a Face now this
was kind of weird to me because I feel
like
You know despite the storied French
tradition of uh you know Grandeur which
you know in terms of Live Theater where
you know if you don't know what that is
that was like a it was kind of like a
around like the between the wars I kind
of feel like like early 20th century
where they would do these live shows
where they were trying to do like as
realistic you know it was usually
violence against women there's a
decapitation and murder and stuff like
that and they would try to show stuff
like that was really really real and
like really gory but even though they
had that tradition of like going overtly
horror like in theater for whatever
reason French filmmakers
um were kind of slower to jump on the
bandwagon they didn't really want to do
that maybe it was because of some
particular strain of I don't know like
artistic elitism or something like that
I mean although the Grand Canyon was
attended by you know Royal people and
like celebrities and stuff like that
like in the early years of the 20th
century like I said it still did have
something of like a sensationalistic and
maybe kind of like a low brow Allure to
it I mean they even had to like boxes
that you could rent like for patrons if
you thought you were gonna get too like
sexually aroused by seeing all the
violence and Gore and stuff so they knew
that people were like jerking it in
there you know what I mean so they were
at least they knew that there was like
some kind of like thing between sex and
violence but I still kind of feel like
the perception of it was that it was
kind of like low brow but filmmaking in
France was kind of seen as more of an
art form and I guess because of that
like a lot of critics felt like horror
films were sort of like beneath contempt
now obviously like back in the old days
like of silent film like in the late
19th century early 20th century had like
George melie and people like that that
were doing kind of like Fantasia's or
like fantasy based films but they
weren't really horror films per se
although there were a couple that kind
of skirted with horror but they were
usually like kind of funnier or they
were like trick films so enter producer
Jules borkol now he decided he was gonna
Buck the trend and see if he could make
some kind of Splash with a movie in the
very lined horror genre so he bought the
rights to a novel by a guy named Jean
radall and this was a novel about an
obsessive plastic surgeon who is
attempting a face transplant on his
disfigured daughter
so he bought the rights to the book and
then he hired the writing team of Pierre
wallow and Thomas narka narca Jack or
narka Jack I think is how you pronounce
that last name they also wrote Because I
think I brought up their names when I
talked about uh Lei day oblique because
they actually wrote the novel that Lei
de I believe was based on and they also
wrote the novel that Alfred Hitchcock's
vertigo was based on so it's those are
the two guys that wrote the screenplay
and then he brought on the director
George franju who had actually not
directed anything but documentaries up
until 1958 when he made his kind of
first foray into like fictional
filmmaking uh with a movie that was
called head against the walls or late
Contra Le mere I don't know I haven't
take for a long time so I'm sure I'm
pronouncing that wrong but it means in
English it means head against the walls
now from the beginning
the team that we're making Eyes Without
a Face they had to tread very carefully
the source novel uh focused very heavily
on a mad scientist which was a topic
that the German centers would not be all
that uh enthused about for obvious
reasons
um also featured like some animal
cruelty or animal experimentation uh
which you know with British sensors that
was a big no-go there and the novel was
also excessively gory like excessively
bloody uh and French sensors were not
going to have too good a time with that
like they wouldn't approve of it
so they figured well maybe we can tweak
the story a little bit to center a
little bit more around the sympathetic
daughter character rather than the mad
scientist character so much so by doing
that they kind of hoped that they would
avoid too many problems you know with
the sensors as it turned out though
um all of their efforts were pretty much
for naught they didn't really run into
any problems with the sensors which is
actually kind of crazy to me like if
you've seen the one famous scene from
this I'm just like oh my God they let
that pass in Europe okay but like
because it was like you know more tame
or [ __ ] than that later on that they
didn't let pass I know it was different
people but you know what I mean it was
like a different time but it seemed to
like pass through the sensors okay but
like when the movie came out in the
theaters critics were not real uh
appreciative they either dismissed it or
they completely Savaged it like some of
the critics just called it sickening uh
some just kind of wrote it off as like a
plotting German expressionist retread
[ __ ] like that like no one was all that
enthused about it several writers and
critics also wondered why a respected
filmmaker like George franju would
debase himself by making a horror film
because that's pretty much how they saw
horror films just like bottom of the
barrel and also a lot of audiences
seemed a little um unequipped to handle
the film's more grisly sequences like I
said there's one very famous one in here
uh and apparently and I don't know if
this is true or not because I know they
say this about a lot of horror movies
even as recently as like the new
terrifier 2 movie
um you know the audiences are like
fainting away in their theater seats and
whatever so you know a lot of people
were having a hard time like which I I
could see like in 1960 I could see it
like nowadays no I don't think anybody's
fainting nowadays but maybe in 1960 yeah
I could maybe see that so two years
after it's European release and like I
said I don't think it really did all
that great it was just kind of like meh
whatever or ew that's disgusting
um the film actually got trimmed of its
more like excessive elements I guess
like some of the gore and stuff and then
it was dubbed into English and that it
was released in the United States under
the completely nonsensical title the
horror chamber of Dr Faustus which has
absolutely nothing to do with anything
that is going on in this movie other
than there's a doctor in it that's
pretty much the only thing so uh the
horror chamber of Dr Faust is actually
kind of played around the country on a
double bill with another mad scientist
movie which was uh called the manster
which is like an American movie but it
was shot in Japan eventually though as
usually happens with movies that were
kind of like ahead of their time George
franju's like you know singular film
would get the appreciation that it
originally deserved and today obviously
it's considered a highly significant
piece of art in the horror genre in
particular uh very it has been very
favorably compared to like the work of
Jean cocktail
um and a lot of people's uh best horror
movies of all time lists like a lot of
critics and stuff like that it comes up
on pretty much every top 100 you know
horror movies ever made it almost always
turned ends up on this list now it is
pretty tame by today's standards
although not as tame as you might be
thinking but
um I am going to say that Eyes Without a
Face was like an enormous Leap Forward I
guess in terms of what a mainstream
horror movie could show and although
like I said it was unfairly scorned I
feel like at the time that it was
released it has been nowadays it's kind
of come to be seen as like an important
milestone in
I guess we're just like a still ongoing
battle to have horror like be taken
taken as seriously as any other like
more acceptable genre I mean we've come
a long way in that regard but we're
still really not all the way there so
Eyes Without a Face begins with a great
setup it just pulls you right into the
story
so there's this anxious looking woman
and she's driving a car like along the
road as you do now she looks into her
rear view mirror like they pan across
and she's kind of checking on there's
somebody in the back seat a woman who's
kind of wearing like a coat and hat and
it's like you're not really sure if
she's unconscious or drunk or dead or
what's the deal uh so yes she's like
looking back there kind of looking
around making sure nobody's looking in
the car [ __ ] like that she's acting
super Shifty
so then she proceeds on to this kind of
secluded spot along a riverbank and then
uh proceeds to dump the woman's body in
the river
we then jump over to our scientist
character whose name is Dr janessier and
uh he's giving a lecture about a new
technique that he's been working on to
kind of like graft living tissue and
organs essentially
now after the talk he gets a phone call
turns out that the police have fished
out the woman's body that we saw earlier
like out the river and because the
woman's description fits the description
of Dr janessier's daughter Christiane
whose face was mutilated in a car
accident sometime before and who
disappeared 10 days ago the cops want
him to come down and have a look and say
maybe this is your daughter who's got
who has been missing so the doctor goes
down to the morgue and confirms that yes
this faceless dead girl in the river is
indeed his daughter Case Closed not so
fast though
it so happens that another woman who is
about the same age and of a similar
description to Christiane also went
missing not long before now this girl
obviously had a face like last time she
was seen uh but otherwise resemble
Christian enough that the authorities
had also called that girl's dad like to
come down and possibly identify the body
Dr janessier got there first though and
he actually says yes my daughter like I
said case closed and then he runs into
the other dad in the parking lot and
then the other guy is like are you sure
that that was your daughter and he's
like yeah I'm sure and then he just
starts being a real dick to the guy
because now the guy thinks that his
daughter you know his daughter is still
missing and he's like I don't know what
to do and he's kind of hoping to like
commiserate with Dr janessier but Dr
genessia is basically like nope ain't
got time for that like oh I'm supposed
to comfort you my daughter's dead [ __ ]
off it's like that kind of thing I'm
like that's what old ass [ __ ]
you know what I mean yeah so later on
we're back at Dr janessier's fancy pad
and we immediately know that something
untoward is up because not only did we
see the woman who was dumping the body
earlier that she lives here too uh it
turns out this is Louise the doctor's
assistant but we also see a young woman
lying face down in a bedroom who is
clearly Dr janessier's daughter and is
just as clearly neither missing nor dead
so it comes to light that the automobile
accident uh Christian was in essentially
obliterated her face like aside from her
eyes that's all that was undamaged and
her desperate and gonna say slightly
maniacal dad has become engrossed in the
task of finding a new face to graft onto
hers I don't know if I want to say
maniacal because he's very cold like I
said which like I said is what is kind
of what makes it scary about him but
it's just maniacal in the sense that
he's like obsessive like he's I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna do this you know what
I mean he just like keeps working on it
even though he keeps failing so it's
like that it's it's this relentlessness
that's actually kind of like creepy
about him so he's been experimenting on
some poor little dogs that he keeps all
caged up in the garage but now he's
resorted to kidnapping girls and
stealing their faces pretty much uh
problem is the operations that he's
attempted so far have been unsuccessful
like Christian's body rejected the skin
grafts and she started to become
increasingly convinced that her dad is
not going to succeed in this endeavor
um now while she's around the house
she's actually encouraged to wear this
very unsettling looking mask like to
cover up her injuries like the mask is
all white and it's expressionless like
only the eyes show through I feel like
maybe this mask is kind of where the
idea for like Michael Myers maybe came
from because it's kind of looks like
that it's not rubbery or like it doesn't
move it's just like it's completely like
static so it's just kind of like over
her face like that so anyway at this
point in the movie it should be obvious
that the body that Dr janessier
identified earlier was obviously not his
daughter it was the body of that other
missing girl whose dad had arrived too
late to the morgue like I said that
makes that scene even more [ __ ] up in
retrospect because DR janessier had to
be like I said some cold ass
[ __ ] to stand there with this
Stern ass face and tell that guy that
his own daughter was dead when he knew
damn well that the body in there was
actually that guy's daughter you know
what I mean and then for him to be a
dick to him like to oh man that's [ __ ]
up anyway like doctor SCA figures that
having everybody think Christian is dead
will kind of like suit his purposes
better and he even has a funeral for her
and everything at which of course the
other missing girl is buried in her
stead so after that uh Dr janessier
tasks his assistant Louise incidentally
whose face he also kind of like restored
to Beauty although hers wasn't as [ __ ]
up as Christians as Christians was so
you know it took a lot better I guess uh
so he tells Louise we need to go out and
find another girl whose face we can
steal pretty much so Louise sets out
like all over Paris like looking for a
suitable candidate
um so she soon finds one in the form of
Edna who is this you know pretty young
student who's looking for a room for
rent
so that's kind of how she kind of like
spends a little while like befriending
the girl and then she's like oh I know
this place that has a room for rent so
she basically lures her out to this the
doctor's like isolated manner where they
live and then she gets her in there even
though like Edna is clearly like real
wary about she's like I don't like this
[ __ ] situation like when she's
driving out there she's like what the
[ __ ] this is like way the hell out in
the suburbs this isn't what I wanted but
she's like oh it'll be fine it'll be
fine like once she gets in there she's
like yeah I gotta go but then they you
know the doctor comes up behind in
chloroform sir essentially and uh you
know just kind of sets about
peeling off her face uh to slap onto his
daughter's face so you know
it's a little [ __ ] up so now this
surgery scene which I said is very very
famous it's I guess it's pretty tame to
like Modern Eyes but I'm trying to cast
myself back to 1960 and people must have
been like absolutely flabbergasted by
saying this [ __ ] like it must have been
like you know just stomach churning I
mean the camera absolutely it does not
flinch at all as Dr janessi is just like
basically slicing around the perimeter
of Edna's face with the scalpel just
like that and then slowly kind of like
inserting the scalpel like underneath
the facial skin like he's separating it
from the muscles underneath and then
ease and the whole thing off like in one
intact piece and like the face kind of
like all bloody and [ __ ] up underneath
even in black and white it's pretty
gruesome because you didn't usually see
like sometimes you would see like some
bloody stuff in it but they'd usually
like cut away well like look at psycho
like look at the shower scene like they
didn't actually show a knife going into
Janet Lee or anything like that they
just implied it this way one absolutely
does not imply it's just it's looking
right at it like the whole time it's
like cut cut cut cut cut cut
you know what I mean it's like that so
I'm like
that's pretty hardcore for 1960 it was
um I think the creepiest thing about it
though
I mean other than you know aside from
how shocking it must have been in 1960
was that it feels very detached like I
think that's one of the reasons that I
said earlier that I thought this movie
was like a little more disturbing than
psycho or peeping Tom it's just because
it's so like chillingly like
dispassionate both in the way that the
violence is framed like the way that the
surgery is framed and in the portrayal
of Dr janessier himself who just comes
across as this very very cold I mean he
loves his daughter he's doing all of
this for her because he loves her and he
wants to restore her to her to normal or
whatever but he's just like so
relentless in his Pursuit that he's just
gone completely off the deep end but
he's just like completely like Stern and
emotionless about it and it's really
really creepy by contrast though like
Christiane is you know obviously she's
going to be the focus of our empathy in
this movie and she kind of like moves
around the manor house almost like a
ghost you know what I mean she has like
these kind of flowing house dresses on
because she can't leave the house you
know so she just has these they're not
robes but exactly but like a house dress
like fancy and she's wearing that really
spooky blank mask so like you can't see
like any of her expression you can't see
her face so the acting performance here
by um Ada scope I think is how you
pronounce her last name
um is actually like extraordinary she
she conveys so much emotion like so much
guilt and anguish and despair like just
through her eyes and the way that she
moves she has these very very slow like
very deliberate movements and she's very
she's a very small woman she's very
fragile and very bird-like and so she
comes across as just like very
vulnerable and wounded and you can't
even see her facial expression so it's
like it's outstanding now she's also
clearly very conflicted about all of the
horrors that her father is perpetrating
in order to restore her beauty or
whatever but at first it seems at least
that she kind of feels powerless to do
anything about it and for a time at
least for a little while in the middle
there it would have appear that maybe
all this killing that they're doing is
maybe going to Bear some fruit after all
because they cut off Edna's face and
then like you know they dump her body
too and they successfully graphed Edna's
face onto Christian and Christian is
actually beautiful again like you get to
see her without the mask like with the
facial graft like on there but she's
still clearly not sure that this she's
you know she's having a dilemma like is
this all worth it because you know all
these girls and dogs and stuff like how
to die for her to get that face back as
the days pass however her body again
starts to reject this new face as well
and I mean the brief period of time
where she was lovely again makes her
return to deformity I guess like hit
even harder to the point where now she
just wants to die she's just like not
having it she's sick of it now her
father again he's Relentless and he's
still adamant that he can fix her he can
you know keep doing it and he does
actually kidnap another woman like for
that very purpose but in the end um you
know like I said Christian is just like
not having it anymore she's not going to
go along with this evil and um so it's
kind of her deciding to do that and
there's also kind of a thing where her
uh former fiancee who still thinks she's
dead
um he's starting to have like some
suspicions because Christiane like calls
him sometimes she calls him just so she
can like hear his voice but obviously
she's not supposed to talk to him
because she's supposed to be dead but at
one point she does like say his name and
he's like oh my God that sounds like her
so then he starts like reporting it to
the police the police kind of start
looking into uh this little nefarious
situation there so there's a little bit
of that going on you know so a
combination of those things kind of like
brings about the downfall of like the
mad scientist right it's like Christian
decides she's not having this anymore
she actually frees the latest captive
like the girl whose face they were gonna
cut off uh she kills Louise
um and releases all the dogs which I was
like yeah she released the dogs at least
most people wouldn't think of that but
she did she released all the dogs that
the doctor had been experienced
fermenting on and in a satisfying bit of
poetic justice at the end the dogs
actually Maul the doctor to death and
then chew off his face that's Chris
Christian like wanders off into the
forest so I mean if you haven't seen it
like Eyes Without a Face it's a
fantastic film I mean it's elegantly
shot like especially like the early
shots with all the fog and everything
like that it's just beautiful beautiful
looking
um it just has superb acting
performances like I said particularly
Ada scope who acts so much just with her
eyes and like with her movements because
she can't see any of her expressions and
at times it has like some really
unnerving scenes like a lot of that
having to do with like the mask and like
the surgery scene and everything like
that I kind of feel like it's been
defined as maybe being closer to like
Noir or maybe being closer to like a
thriller than a straight horror film but
I'm not really sure if people are just
saying that because they don't want to
call it a horror film because it's
really good and it's like an art film
and again there's that little like I
said it's not as bad as it used to be
but I still kind of feel like there's a
little bit of a stigma around horror
still so I maybe that's why people call
it that I mean I'm not sure I agree
though I mean I think this is a horror
film if anything is a horror film it's
essentially a mad scientist story and
the thing about it is that it's
influenced so many subsequent
horror and like horror adjacent films
like Jess Franco said that this was um a
big influence on a lot of his movies
um the movie The Skin I live in uh Pedro
Al madovar that was uh that was kind of
like an homage to this movie as well I
mean I'm not really sure how you could
call it anything else I'm pretty sure
it's just a straight horror horror movie
um and I don't know why their people are
reluctant to call it that also it has
kind of like this dream like like a
fairy tale quality to it a little bit
and that really like juxtaposes very
effectively with the clinical atrocities
I guess like all the killings and stuff
and all the face cutting and stuff that
the doctor is doing and that's one of
the things that really gives it that
horror Edge I feel like
um I mean at any rate it's you know it's
rightly considered a classic at this
point and for good reason
um if you have any passing interest at
all in you know Horror in a serious
interest in horror like seeing like the
roots of the stuff then you absolutely
have to see it like sooner rather than
later it's really really good and I
really really recommend it if you
haven't seen it it um I watched it on
HBO Max but I'm sure you can find it uh
somewhere else as well and as I said if
you really if you want to know anything
about the history of horror it's really
one that you have to see because it's
really really influential so that will
do it for this flickers if you're hope
you guys enjoyed it and I'll see you
guys again on the next one bye